Let's take a step back here and
talk about why we even care
whether we have outliers.
Remember that what we're working through
here is not just some academic exercise,
but typically we're analyzing our data
to help us answer a business question.
Maybe why a certain
behavior is happening or
maybe even to be able to predict
what might happen in the future.
To do that we want to have our data
as close to reality as possible.
And that's where the identification
of outliers comes into play.
Lots of times data that is unusual or
extreme can be that way for
one of two reasons.
One, incorrect data, or two,
abnormal but correct data.
Data can be incorrect for any number
of reasons, from system issues
to bad data collection methods to
just plain typos when entering data.
The critical thing to understand
is that this incorrect data
can mess with our answers
to our business questions,
whether we're trying to explain why
something happened a certain way.
Or what might happened in the future.
Abnormal, but correct outliers
despite being accurate data can
also impact your analysis and you may
have to make adjustments accordingly.
So by identifying those data
values that might be incorrect,
we have the means to possibly
correct them if they're wrong.
Or understand the exceptions
that are real.
Actually, by the nature of data,
we can expect to find extreme
data in almost any data.
So, the fact that they are outliers,
doesn't necessarily mean
they're invalid or incorrect.
But we should know that they're there so
we can adjust our
analysis appropriately.
An example of this would be in our
income data that we just went over.
Say we're trying to analyze some
behavior of our customers...
Based on their level of income.
Our data shows that most of our
customers make under $100,000.
So if we see in our data that there's
a single customer that makes $1 million,
we might want to try to confirm
that this is truly the case.
Or we might not want to consider
that customer in our analysis.
Since it may skew our
thinking away from reality.
This leads us to the question of
what effect outliers can have on
our analysis.